it's happening again another video oh my
god hi you guys my name is grace Helbig
if you do not know now you know your
life is different now
it is grace member sorry that's annoying
but for those of you that are new get
caught up it's the first Tuesday screws
day of grace member which means I just
wasn't a name that rhymed with Tuesday
and I didn't fully think through what
Tuesday videos would be in the most
broad sense it's just a day that I screw
around so I decided to create a new
YouTube challenge because a lot of
YouTube is fueled by challenges a very
heavily edited version of someone's real
live and make up I've created many a
dumb challenge here on YouTube but let's
put it on my face mayonnaise will I put
it on my face yes I like things on your
head that have never been on your head
before wireless mouse tireless mirror a
rechargeable vibrator and this is no
exception
I'm so excited for it I'm calling this
challenge I'm creating a challenge in
which you have one minute to draw as
many dicks on your face as possible and
then you challenge other people to do
that same thing and then you see who can
draw the most dicks on their face this
is important and this is meaningful and
it's powerful so far my rules are you
can only do the face no neck and you
have to I mean I don't want to make too
many rules let's stop talking and let's
start [ __ ] around I'm gonna set my
alarm for one minute I'm using this
black eyeliner that I know I can just
pump up if I run out phallic nature of
this doesn't stop okay ready set 1
minutes a dicket start okay oh good okay
I have a mirror here with me too oh boy
did I mean you can't I'm I know the
strategy is I don't have to share ideas
the strategy is that there's no judge
here there's no jury to tell me what's a
dick on it's not a dick and every dick
is totally different so no one can make
fun of the way I'm [ __ ] around here
oh my god the mouth wasn't the best
place to start let's go up to the
forehead okay here we go
oh halfway through I'm now
this dick oh my eyeliners running out go
up go up okay here we go oh my god I'm
setting the bar so limp no go Dick's go
six go dicks I went to college I'm 32
how about you oh no no turning into
hearts I don't know what the symbolism
is there three seconds up oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god alright the
one-minute ticket challenge has come to
a close for me how many dicks did I get
let's see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20 much fun oh wow I mean no
one that I know has done this before so
we don't know if that's a good or bad
showing but I do know that I look
beautiful and I do know that my family
is proud of me I should tag people in
the minute to dick it challenge right
okay I'm gonna challenge Liza Koshi
maybe she'll do it on her second Channel
I'm gonna challenge Hannah because
she'll just be wholly uncomfortable with
this completely and I'm also gonna
challenge mamrie because she'll probably
be really good at this memmer's
competitive by nature but also I just
feel like she'll be really good at this
so there you go I challenge you three
ladies to the minute to dicket chill
thank you guys for watching Tuesday's
cruise day here on it's grace for the
month of grace member I'm making videos
Monday through Friday don't forget to
subscribe so that you don't miss a
single beautiful piece of art click that
Bell notifications so you know in eppela
because it's it varies and let me know
in the comments down below what kind of
videos you want to see for the rest of
grace member other than that I don't
know let me double check my math on 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 20 22 and mean like t-swift says
I feel Court
[Music]